You can't have a good Pixar movie without
a bunch of Easter eggs, right?
There are more than a few to spot in Finding
Dory, the long-awaited 2016 sequel to Finding
Nemo.
Let's dive in and find out what you might
have missed during the movie.
And it should go without saying, but there
are ​spoilers ahead​.
Darla strikes back?
When Dory gets taken into the Marine Life
Center's quarantine room, she looks over at
a bulletin board with a photo of a very familiar
girl with headgear pinned to it.
That's right, if you're quick enough, you
can spot a picture of Darla, the fish-tormenting
girl from the original Finding Nemo.
Of course, just why there's a picture of an
Australian girl in a Californian Marine Life
Center, we just can't answer.
Maybe her reputation for torturing our finny
friends has spread across the Pacific Ocean.
Wired
The movie's two sea lion characters, Fluke
and Rudder, are voiced by Idris Elba and Dominic
West, respectively.
These two actors starred in the HBO series
The Wire, with Idris playing Russell 'Stringer'
Bell and West playing Detective Jimmy McNulty.
As Fluke and Rudder, they sit on a rock and
help Nemo and Marlin find their way into the
Marine Life Center, all while keeping their
spot safe from other sea lions like Gerald:
"Ha, mate, don't you worry-"
(Sea lions yelling)
Maybe not the same level of drama as ​The
Wire​, but you take what you can get in
a kid's movie.
A113
Fluke and Rudder also happen to hide another
Easter egg.
As pointed out by the Pixar Post blog, merchandise
featuring the characters have tags on their
flippers that read "A1" and "13."
That's a reference to the classroom at the
California Institute of the Arts where many
of the Pixar and Disney animators learned
their craft, and it's appeared in every Pixar
movie ever released, not to mention more than
a few Disney movies, too.
The Pizza Planet Truck rides again
You can also spot the the famed Pizza Planet
Truck from the original ​Toy Story​ when
Hank and Dory steal the transport truck headed
for Cleveland.
We're not sure how many different Pizza Planet
franchises there are throughout time and space,
but this beat-up, yellow truck sure gets around.
It's appeared in just about every Pixar flick.
Wall-E calendar
In the scene where Hank the septopus hangs
from the pipes above the Open Ocean tank,
there's a small desk in the top right corner
of the screen.
Above that desk is a calendar that reads "Wall-E."
It would have also been cool to see some Buy'n'Large
items littered around, giving some credence
to the theory that these Pixar movies are
all part of the same shared (and ultimately
doomed) world.
But, sure, a calendar is fine too.
Herbie the Love Bug
Be on the lookout for a familiar face...kind
of.
Buried down on the ocean floor is the world's
most famous 1963 Volkswagen Beetle, Herbie
the Love Bug.
Of course, as cute as the deep Disney reference
is...it's actually a pretty creepy spot for
Herbie's final resting place.
Who knows, maybe this is one of those Easter
eggs that Pixar sticks into their movies that
hints at a future film.
Maybe they'll take on a Herbie movie of their
own?
Or better yet, maybe he'll make his comeback
in Cars 3...
Ride reminder
According to Ultimate Orlando, one of the
pipes in the Marine Life Center reads "Seawater
Supply TL59."
That's a reference to the Finding Nemo Submarine
Voyage at Disneyland in Anaheim, California.
This explanation doesn't stop there, either:
the attraction used to be called simply the
Submarine Voyage, but was re-themed after
the success of the film.
The pipe was included on the line to the ride
as a tribute to its former, non-Nemo-themed
existence.
Return of the Tank Gang
If you managed to sit through the credits,
enjoying various snippets of Hank using his
camouflaging abilities in different locations,
then you'd be treated to a post-credits scene
featuring the sea lions Fluke and Rudder hanging
out on their rock.
And who should happen to come swimming past
them?
The Tank Gang from Finding Nemo.
Brad Garrett, Willem Dafoe and the rest came
back to reprise their roles so we could see
where the gang wound up.
Hank, the greatest Easter egg of them all
Did you know that Hank the septopus actually
appeared in every one of Pixar's movies without
anyone ever realizing it?
It's true!
Well, at least according to Finding Dory​
director Andrew Stanton and Hank's voice actor,
Ed O'Neill, who appeared in a video explaining
that Hank had been camouflaged into every
Pixar movie since the first ​Toy Story​
hit theaters way back in 1995.
Wait, what?
Oh, that video was published on April 1, 2016.
So...ya never mind.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
Easter eggs we missed…